est il devenu invisible depuis le 1er
janvier oui un petit peu invisible c'est
vrai mais là je suis là c'est pas une
vraie vidéo comme d'habitude je vais
essayer d'être très con si je me suis
dit on est quand même le 3 janvier il
serait temps que je leur dise que je
compte faire cette année bah je vais
faire des vidéos alors si je vous disais
tout ce que je vais faire cette année
c'est trop long donc on va faire court
on va déjà juste parler du mois de
chambre dans un premier temps je vais
prendre quelques jours de vacances mais
vous allez avoir déjà une vidéo ce
vendredi matin parce que j'ai tourné une
vidéo et je vois pas pourquoi je le
sortirai pas ensuite c'est sûr pendant
peut-être quinze jours il va y avoir
moins beaucoup moins deux vidéos que
d'habitude puisque roselyne par jour
pour la simple et bonne raison que je me
reposais un peu en apparence parce qu'en
réalité je commence ma tournée par
exemple 6 et 7 janvier je suis à lille
dans 59 le 11 et le 12 janvier je suis à
saint galmier dans le 42 le 13 janvier à
villars dans le 42 aussi le 14 janvier à
vienne dans le 38 comme le 15 janvier le
21 janvier dans le 83 à brignoles et du
25 au 29 janvier dans le xiii à aix en
provence
à chaque fois on verra à la fin des
spectacles je prends du temps avec vous
les dernières fois qu'on a fait ça en
suisse et à paris on a passé plus de
temps à se voir après que le spectacle
en lui-même et c'est cool que j'aime
bien bref pour les dates de spectacles
vous avez un lien dans la description
donc concernant les vidéos un petit peu
de pauses au départ et puis après je
vais reprendre à deux trois vidéos par
semaine ça dépendra des semaines dans un
premier temps il y aura pas de jour
spécifique de sortie il aura pas d'heure
spécifique de sortie donc vraiment
cliqué sur la petite cloche pour être
sûr d'être notifiés pas rater les vidéos
et il y aura une vidéo ou de un petit
peu plus grosse et spéciales dont une
qui sortira qu'à la toute fin du mois le
dernier jour de janvier ce sera une
grosse vidéo avec une grosse surprise
dedans et puis c'est tout forcément
comme j'ai eu un petit peu plus de temps
je me suis pas mal éclaté pour monter la
vidéo de vendredi j'espère vraiment que
ça vous plaira et vous serez au rendez
vous pour la voir je serai pas tout seul
c'est dedans avec quelqu'un et je vous
donnerai un indice dans cette vidéo
à vous de trouver une dernière chose
j'ai bien lu tous vos commentaires sur
ce que vous aimeriez voir ou pas sur la
chaîne et ça m'a beaucoup servi dans
merci beaucoup des six autres choses je
vais lancer des vidéos qui vont se faire
avec vous des espèces d'expérience qu'on
va faire ensemble donc suivant les
besoins à chaque fois soit je ferai une
vidéo ça s'appellera expérience est ce
que vous voulez participer quelque chose
comme ça et tout sera expliqué dedans et
parfois ce sera plus simple affaire et
je mettrai directement
messages sur les réseaux sociaux vous
avez aussi les liens dans la description
je crois que j'ai rien oublié si ce
n'est que de vous souhaiter une très
très très très bonne année 2010 est ça
fait bizarre de pu avoir plein de
commentaires à lire tous les jours et
voilà c'est un nouveau rythme qui
s'installe à très bientôt à vendredi
matin over
[Musique]